[Music]
hello this is my fully automatic fully
expandable and customizable create crop
Farm which uses the Gantry Carriage
system so first I'm going to explain how
the machine works and we're going to
build it if you've seen my tree farm
Design This is essentially the same
machine but without the flipping saw so
let's get into it this is essentially
our main machine we have Harvesters
connected to a Gantry Carriage which
goes along our Gantry shaft here we have
two Redstone contacts on each end of the
Gantry shaft to detect when the
Harvester has arrived on either end of
the machine each of the Redstone contact
is connected to a redstone link when our
Harvester arrives at either end of the
farm our Redstone contact will send a
redstone signal through this link which
will then be received by this Redstone
receiver this Redstone receiver will
then send a signal to toggle or toggle
LEDs which will then power or on power
our gearshift this gear shift if powered
will then reverse the rotation of our
Gantry shaft moving the machine back and
forth a ganty cage will move along the
ganty shaft depending on its
rotation if we reverse the rotation the
ganty cage will come towards us and if
we don't the gany cage will move away
from us so this is mainly how we're
moving our Harvesters here now this you
know how the farm Works let's build it
first set up your Gantry shaft this can
be as long or short as you need then
Place The ganty Carriage on one end and
linear chassis on top of it now this can
be as long or short as you need as well
then you want to put your Harvesters on
both sides of the
chassis once that's done you want to put
the Redstone contacts on both ends of
the Gantry carriage and then you want to
put the connections to those Redstone
contacts from the other end skip one
block and put it
here then you want to connect Redstone
links to your Redstone contacts
then you want to give your machine some
storage and a portable storage interface
for the output and then you can finally
glue them all
together um quick note on either end of
your gante shaft skip one block before
you start planting your crops if you
start planting your crops here or here
um your crops will be uprooted because
this is where your machine is going to
rest every time it's going to change
directions so just from this one end
skip one block and then this is where
you start planting same on this side as
well this is the end of the ganed cage
skip one block this is where you're
going to start planting your crops when
that's all done you want to connect your
gante shaft to two normal shafts and
then here you can connect your gear
shift if you connect your gear shift
here um these Redstone contacts will
power your gear shift and it will break
your machine so just skip two uh leave
these two alone and then put your gear
shift here then you want to connect your
gear shift to a toggled power lch if you
don't want an off switch you can just
put put the rest link directly next to
the toggle power ledge but if you want
an off switch place a block next to the
toggle power ledge skip one block place
your link here a normal repeater facing
into the block a sticky piston facing to
the block and a lever to toggle the off
switch this is on this is off now very
important you need to set up a unique
frequency for your Redstone link so it
doesn't mess up with other Redstone l in
your world this example we're going to
use a sticky piston
here and also to make a redstone link
into a receiver you can either shift
right click or you can use a wrench as
you can see it's now getting powered
because it's on the same frequency so to
turn the machine on just flip the lever
and there you go the machine is
on another quick note rotation speed
doesn't really matter if your rotation
speed is faster that means your
Harvester will go faster um but it does
generally affect the performance of the
farm so yeah you can put just one water
wheel or however much you need right now
for just take of example we're using a
32 RPM uh water wheel but yeah you can
make this into an 8 RPM or like a 16 RPM
it doesn't matter it's all good so now
the last thing to do is to set up your
output your storage output so what you
want to do is to find your ganty cage
skip one block so it's here and then you
want to find the level at which your
storage output is on the machine itself
you want to put it here nope want to put
it here facing towards the machine you
want to set up a funnel and two chests
and you have a choot above it you can
either use hoppers or shoots whatever
you need so there basically the machine
set up now as you can see this will
unload the crops into our shoot and into
the
chest that is it for the fully automatic
fully customizable and expandable crop
Farm using the create mode I hope you
enjoyed this video and I will see you in
the next one bye-bye